afghan refugee mir safi spoke with
global news earlier this week as his
seven family members including a newborn
baby slept on the floor of a ukrainian
school near the polish border safi says
they were blocked from leaving ukraine
four times in the past week there have
been many reports of non-ukrainians
facing discrimination while trying to
leave particularly visible minorities
it's very frustrating to see ukrainians
cross the border without being asked to
stop but me as an afghan they stopped me
and they say my baby daughter does not
have papers the safi's daughter sumiya
was born one day before the invasion
this was all the ukrainian border
authorities they didn't even give me
time to speak the safes finally made it
out wednesday night and are now in
germany
for the safees this is the second
traumatic departure in six months they
fled the taliban last august and applied
to come to canada hoping to have been
approved long before now will the
minister look into this case and help
this family and others like them come to
canada expeditiously we can't discuss
the specifics of any case i'm happy to
look into whatever sensitive cases
may come across our desk
just like the hawk malls whom global
news spoke with in february the safis
are unsure when their case will be
processed two families praying to find
peace caught up in two brutal conflicts
redmond shannon global news london